c'est pas mes copains ça je ne sais pas
qui sont les amis de Gilbert mais c'est
la France insoumise
[Rires]
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a glissé ça je ne
sais pas
vous avez un peu le un look à emericon
peut-être qu'il y a une alarme
tu MP 2008 à 2008 donc c'est pas voilà
alors moi j'ai écouté attentivement ce
que vous avez dit ce matin mon
chercharge je vous respecte beaucoup je
vous aime c'est odieux ce que vous avez
dit franchement c'est un qualifiable et
moi je vais vous dire vous vous êtes en
privilégié Charles vous êtes né avec une
cuillère en or dans la bouche si vous
avez été épaulé dès l'enfance
vous avez été aidé par vos parents
depuis le départ et vous commencez à
dire que des gens devraient se casser le
cul se lever bouger pour trouver un
travail mais la France c'est un pays
inégalitaire il y a plein de gens des
cités plein de jeunes qui voudraient
bosser qui trouve pas de boulot il y a
des discriminations il y a des gens qui
sont rejetés par le marché du travail
c'est à eux que vous voudriez vous
adresser plutôt que de parler entre
privilégiés voilà pas du tout je vais
vous répondre d'abord on n'était pas
entre privilégié sur ce plateau puisque
Étienne leblig le chroniqueur dont il
s'agit et pas particulièrement souvent
vous parlez à vous-même donc vous êtes
un peu narcissique
je me parle je me parle pas moi-même du
tout je pense que
justement il est de la responsabilité
des gouvernants de prendre ça en compte
cette envie de justice dans le pays et
c'est vrai qu'en France il y a plus
d'ascenseurs sociales aujourd'hui moi je
vois les jeunes qui sont normales pour
une grande part d'entre eux leurs
parents étaient anormal sup les nains
etc donc ça c'est sûr qu'il y a quelque
chose à faire c'est sûr que aujourd'hui
les salaires de ce qu'on a appelé
pendant le covid avec des larmes de
crocodile les premiers de corvées sont
trop faibles et moi je ne vois pas pour
l'instant ce qui est fait là-dessus j'ai
lu la dernière interview du président de
la République qui renvoie au dialogue
social et aux entreprises pour
l'augmentation des salaires à mon avis
il s'enlève les mains un peu vite
évidemment que tout ça doit être pris en
compte mais justement moi j'en veux à
cette gauche là toujours quand même à la
CGT la CFDT etc qui parce qu'elle
diabolise le travail elle empêche aussi
les gens de s'en sortir en France
aujourd'hui quand vous voulez recruter
quelqu'un quand vous voulez ouvrir votre
magasin tard quand vous voulez ouvrir
votre magasin dimanche quand vous êtes
une start-up qui installe des
trottinette dans Paris qui était la
planche de salut des parisiens pour
survivre à Hidalgo elle a supprimé ça
tout ça ça fait 90% non ça ça a été et
combien de boomer parmi les électeurs
par rapport au nombre de jeunes c'était
une fausse sélectionner tout ça tout ça
tout ça ça crée oui mais elle a fait
exprès tout ça ça crée des conditions
qui font que vous n'avez pas en France
la possibilité de trouver si facilement
du boulot quand vous êtes justement dans
un milieu défavorisé donc je trouve
qu'il y a un grand chantier mais que
c'est pas en revenant à nos vieilles
lunes socialisante qui à mon sens ont
plutôt miné notre pays qu'autre chose
qu'on avancera même si je pense que la
justice ça fait partie de notre noblesse
ça fait partie de l'idéal français c'est
quelque chose qui doit être pris en
compte du luxe dans un projet politique
Gilles pardon mais tu dis n'importe quoi
ma couille déjà en France il y a une
réalité c'est qu'il y a un tabou autour
de l'argent je pense que personne ne
dirait autour de cette table combien il
gagne
pas du tout
mais ce que je n'aime pas chez les gens
comme Gilles c'est qu'il y a des gens
qui pensent que la situation financière
des gens est figée à de vitamine
c'est-à-dire que les pauvres sont
décédés toute leur vie et que les riches
sont dessinés à être riche toute leur
vie mais je suis désolé il y a des mecs
qui ont commencé au SMIC en étant
chauffeur uber qui sont devenus des
grands joueurs de foot des grands
basketteurs des grands patrons des
grands chefs d'entreprise donc ces mecs
là au lieu des jalousies on devrait les
admirer il faut les admirer ce mec là
faut être positif
et c'est vrai que c'est un souci non
parce que je devais la main depuis tout
à l'heure et en fait non je pense que
c'est vraiment un souci moi je le vois
avec les émissions quand on les fait
c'est la question qu'on veut toujours
enlever quand les artistes viennent ils
veulent toujours enlever la question du
salaire et en même temps dans la rue à
chaque fois qu'on pose quelque chose on
dit ah vous donner les vous posez la
question des salaires aux gens la
dernière fois on l'avait fait avec toi
Géraldine je t'avais posé la question du
salaire ça a été sur internet c'est un
truc
moi j'ai aucun problème avec ça mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a une sorte de
suspicion c'est à dire qu'en fait on est
après on est plus légitime pour parler
genre toi qui gagne tous les soirs pour
rien dire tu es hors-sol tu sers à rien
de toute façon tu comprends pas tu sais
pas ce que c'est la vraie galère mais
les gens ne savent pas en fait
connaissent pas la vie des gens ils
savent pas qu'on a 51 51 ans on sait pas
ce qu'on a vécu avant on sait pas où on
en est de notre situation personnelle et
tout ça donc voilà on juge vite et donc
forcément il y a une jalousie